ما هي حدود هذا الرد الفعال الذي يمكن ان
يقده بايدن
الان في للرد على هذه العمليه وما هي
الخيارات المتاحه والمطروح الان امام
الولايات المتحده للرد كما قال بايدن
لحمايه الجنود والمصالح الامريكيه في
المنطقه دون
توسيع
الحرب هذا هذا طبعا
امر صعب جدا بالنسبه لبايدن واعتقد سيكون
الصعب جدا عليه ان لا يوسع الحرب فقد سفكت
دماء امريكيه واذا لم يقم بشيء
ما يوكن كبيرا وواضحا ويجعل الثمن غاليا
بالنسبه لم ارتكب هذا
العمل نحن هذا قد يجعله ضعيفا ول حتى
امريكا ضعيفه اذا انت ترجح ان تذهب
الولايات المتحده الى خيار الحرب هل هذا
مطروح امامها
الان حرف كامله كلا لا اعتقد ولكن هل
امريكا يمكنها ان تقوم بضربات واسعه
وكبيره جدا ضد المجموعات التي يبدو ان هي
المسؤوله عن
هذا مباشره او حتى الهجوم على اهداف
ايرانيه
لاعطائهم وجبه ثانيه من الاهداف الممكنه
جدا